What we have seen now is how delta debugging can take a specific test
and use this specific test in order to automatically simplify
a fairly complex input to an input where every single character is relevant.
So far, however, we need to set up a specific test function for every failure.
Is there a way to come up with generic tests that can be used for arbitrary situation?
Here again, we have a testing function.
And we want to turn this testing function into something that is more generic.
For instance that simply checks whether some assertion has been raised.
Here, I have converted this testing function into something way more generic.
All that's left in here is the call to the function I want to test. In this case, remove HTML marker.
If this function raises an assertion error--for instance because the built-in assertion failed,
then the test fails as well.
If there is no assertion that failed, then this simply return pass.
This test function now can be adapted again and again for arbitrary function
as long as they have an assertion or some other run time check that makes them fail.
Here is a remove HTML marker function from the previous units
and it has an assertion to make sure that the result no longer contain any HTML mark.
And this is precisely what we can test in here.
If the assertion fails and the test will fail and if the assertion does not fail, then the test passes.
Remember this notorious input "HTML to regular text HTML marker."
Which would not work at all when removing HTML marker.
Indeed, this would make the assertion fail because the output would still contain HTML marker.
Now let's go and use delta debugging to minimize this input
such that every character in the input is relevant for producing the error.
For a remove HTML marker, what is the minimal substring of this string
including the double quotes that triggers the failure and as a hint
it's just two characters long--over to you.